we have breaking news we are continuing
to follow for you Iran says 50 people
have now died from the corona virus as
the infection spreads across the Middle
East Kuwait Bahrain and Afghanistan have
all reported their first cases let's go
now to George vari with the latest and
Tehran dorsa this is a significant job
yes not only that but it just a few
minutes ago we've been hearing from the
elected member of parliament from the
city of ohm that is of course the
epicenter of where this corona virus was
first reported he is accusing the Health
Ministry of not being transparent with
the official death toll
he claims that more than nearly 50
people have already died from the virus
involved now this is something the
Health Ministry has not confirmed yet
but it is something that the Health
Ministry MP from home is saying has
taken place he says that also the number
of people that have been confirmed to
have the virus is also much higher than
what the health officials have said so
far now according to the Health Ministry
the number of death has risen and has as
has the number of people that have been
as confirmed to have this disease this
is something the Iranian authorities are
very very cautious about the president
Hassan rouhani has said that he's given
the Health Ministry all the powers they
need to control this disease we've also
been hearing from various other
international airlines Turkish Airlines
has already cancelled all flights in and
out of Iran as of this morning we also
just heard from the Qatari Health
Ministry that any people any passengers
traveling to Qatar from Iran as well as
South Korea will be quarantined for the
14-day period as soon as they enter the
country this is in line with what
measures other neighboring countries
have been taking with Iran they've
countries such as Iraq Afghanistan
Pakistan Turkey they've all closed their
land borders as well the officials here
are adamant that they have the situation
under control they are asking people to
be cautious when they go out in public
spaces all universe
cities and schools have been closed
until next week in about two-thirds of
the country as well as all sporting
events and theater events as well have
all been canceled there is a sense from
many people here that they need to be
very cautious and they also are not
heavily secured and what the information
is that is coming out from the house
ministry they are urging their officials
to be more transparent and to tell the
public what they really you know in
terms of the actual facts that they have
or so what more do we know tell us
remind us again what the source of the
corona was getting into Iran as far as
we know well according to the Health
Ministry there were two cases two men
who one of them at Chinese national
who's working as a construction worker
in the holy city of Homs that is about
120 kilometers south of the capital he
was one of the people that died from the
virus on Wednesday and then the second
case that we heard from that was
reported who was an Iranian national
businessman who traveled to China and
when he came back he tested positive and
subsequently passed away from the
disease those were the two first cases
we heard about that were in the city of
home that was reported last Wednesday
since then health officials have said
that the city is not under quarantine
but they are urging the residents of
that city which is about just over a
million residents to not go outside if
they don't need to to restrict their
movements to only what they need to do
to carry on with their lives but all the
schools the seminaries the holy shrine
that is there has all been they've been
our people have been urged to stay away
from those areas the seminaries have all
been closed as well as the schools there
that is where we heard from initially
this outbreak began in Iran
okay endorse it and actually right now
as you were speaking there's a news
conference that is happening now with
Iranian officials
more about coronavirus let's listen to
that understand the situation if someone
died here are there they will say that
this is due to Corona now this is not
true this is a piece of wrong news and
information and we need to understand
carefully that these news that are
really fools aimed at putting the
officials in a critical situation but we
need to tell you that we are quite aware
of all the information and we have so
many diagnoses and we have so many tests
but for the time being it's not a sort
of a political competition no political
powers should sort a competition in this
regard because the Iranian people should
be and must be the winner at the end of
the day over all these problems I'd like
to stress that we need not to give false
information about the city of pom the
situation is stable now income and some
of those people living income have left
the city because they want to live the
city and if we said such a school or
such a university should not start
working or classes this means that the
people must stay at home not to leave
the city I would like also to say that
20% of those who used to commute to
Jalan City cannot go now because the
Jalan
governrate has some cases of corona and
again and again when a school is closed
or university or whatever people should
stay at home and we need not to
exaggerate the matters we have two
hospitals that are allocated for these
cases and eighty percent of the hospital
capabilities are located for the corona
and other percent is for the other
things that on a daily basis done
services medical services done and given
an offer to the citizens i had like.he
to thank all the medical people nurses
medical staff here and there who worked
in these governmental organizations
because they are doing their job every
single day and despite all the
difficulties they have families they
have kids they have responsibilities but
they are always there to help the
citizens and they need not to go commute
to their houses and come back to the
hospital's they have to stay there and
we have paved the situation in these
hospitals in our nice way for the staff
people to live and spend the nights in
the hospital and I'd like to say that so
many cases were about to be released and
discharged from the hospitals our
doctors are working hard and sacrifice a
lot
before any question I'd like to say that
the government and the president and all
members of the cabinet are quite
committed to their responsibilities the
legal responsibilities and also we will
never get a blind eye to any mistakes or
any pitfalls and everyone has to do his
job
I'd like to tell you that you need to be
assured that any one who died because of
this will be declared so listen to us
the figures are from us the corona virus
is there in so many parts of the world
we can face this virus we need not to
exaggerate because we need not to affect
negatively our citizens and we need not
to hit our security this is our moral
responsibility the Minister of Health
has a spokesperson in this regard and
these information should be reflected
through the spokesperson of the Ministry
of Health on a daily basis we have these
tests and we need to make sure that
everyone is doing his job in his
position what in one of the cases we had
a trader who went to the Emirates and
then he went to China and this man was
the main reason to bring this virus into
our country the government is working
hard I need not to talk too much in this
connection so many countries haven't
dealt with this virus problem in such a
transparency that we follow here in our
country
many countries suffer from this but in
Iran in our country we need to be
professional we need to work hard within
transparency we need to work we need to
continue our approach we need to declare
the reality we need to be always within
transparency and thank you very much
I have a question regarding the chorus
on governrate where you can say that the
coronavirus is there is this true or not
his chorus on corona free governrate or
not we need some information regarding
calm and Tehran as the Minister of
Health discussed this matter I had like
to tell you regarding the previous one
the previous news regarding what has
been mentioned and reported by the media
one or two days ago they were like 50
cases and the news said there are more
and more cases but the reality is if you
love your country we need to be honest
and if you have a piece of news you have
to follow the spokesperson of the
Minister of Health and things that are
not officially declared must not be
dealt with if I know a piece of news I
will tell you and if the death toll has
reached more figures then with even one
case I will tell you and I will resign
because we need to be honest we need to
be transparent and those people are
trying to distort the situation
regarding arson and other regions I'd
like to say that the we deal with the
cases we deal with the symptoms and
we have all the abilities and all the
capabilities to file this virus and if
we have a case that is suspected we will
move it to a better place to be
hospitalized in more than ten governrate
we have the full capabilities to
determine to the teen and to treat and
we will say everything in a clear way we
follow all the governorates we follow
all the cities and even before the World
War one we were against their decisions
of closing whole cities or closing whole
governorates because this has bad
consequences if you close the city or a
governrate what are the citizens they're
supposed to do we have the information
we analyze the information and if we
find a decision that is good we will
apply that decision we need not to
exaggerate we need not someone to say
that the corona virus is all over the
place in our country no we need not that
we have to be up to responsibility and
we have to work closely with all
agencies and we don't agree on closing a
city or a governorate mr. Darwish II I
have a question
regarding the public health in our
country where some medical staff and
some medical personnel just resigned or
don't work properly have you talked to
the media about this have you talked to
the media about this this is not true
because it depends on even the uniform
it depends on the dress of men and women
inside a hospital you cannot do that and
no one has resigned for example if there
is a case a person that is hit by the
virus then the medical staff should deal
with this case in a certain way within a
certain clothing or within a certain
uniforms and gentlemen like this is the
okay you have been listening to
officials updating the situation that is
happening with corona virus that was
Iran's Health Ministry spokesman Roger
achi and Ali Roubaix a government
spokesperson updating the situation on
corona
door Suvari our Dorset Amara is live
listening in Tehran as well so dorsa the
the men were talking about inferencing
emphasizing the importance of
transparency they keep assuring the
world that they will give the proper
numbers but there still is a conflict
between what the Health Ministry is
saying and what an MP and Combs is
saying about the number of deaths right
now from coronavirus and Iran so what do
we know
well the Health Ministry has now
confirmed at the numbers that the that
local MP from home was saying the Health
Ministry is just announced that the
death toll is up to 50 and the number of
confirmed cases that they have in the
country is up to 61 the other important
note to make at this point is that this
presser has been very interesting
because it's the first official
oppressor that we have had over the past
few days since the news first broke last
Wednesday of the death of the first
person in the country as a result of the
virus the officials in this presser Ali
Rabi the government spokesperson said
there aim is to be as transparent as
possible every day the Health Ministry
spokesperson has been appearing on state
TV on the phone giving daily briefings
and death tolls and confirmed cases
across the country but the important
point right now is we've just been
hearing from that MP from home who has
become very vocal he is saying that the
first death occurred in the city of Rome
on February 13th and not as when the
Health Ministry made the announcement
which was February 19th so there is a
gap again that we see between when the
death actually occurred and when the
health officials in the country decided
to make the news public this is
something that is going to be very very
important because president Hassan
rouhani has been under attack
consistently as a result of that
Ukrainian plane passenger plane that was
shot down by mistake early January after
the assassination of Bassam Soleimani
those days that the Iranian officials
denied having anything to do with that
passenger plane coming down killing 176
people on board this is something that
will be very very important in this case
for Iranians because they now are saying
very different informations coming
through from local officials in home and
the Health Ministry ministry officials
and government officials but what we do
know right now after this press
conference is that they are attempting
to control the spread of this disease
they are urging the public not to panic
they say that they have the facilities
the gear to deal with the
outbreak and they are urging people to
just caution to be cautious and exercise
the proper hygiene steps that they've
been telling them on state TV they've
been showing people how to put on masks
and to remind them to wash their hands
consistently a number of public events
have been canceled schools and
universities across the country over
two-thirds of the cities have all been
closed till next week and it will most
likely be extended further at this point
we also know that a number of
international airlines have canceled
flights including Turkish Airlines Qatar
we've just heard that they would be
quarantine people for 14 days upon entry
to the country from Iran these are all
measures being taken by neighboring
countries to try and limit the spread of
this disease but we can confirm also
where this originated the Health
Ministry spokesperson said that they
believe that the Iranian national who
traveled to China via the UAE
is the person who began who carried it
back into the country and he has since
passed away he was the first Iranian
national to die in home last week when
we heard that announcement so a lot of
information coming out also interesting
to note that the local MP from home is
making certain claims that the health
official and government officials have
yet to respond to and you make a valid
point there dorsa that this is the time
when the people really need to be able
to trust their government and it's
coming at a time when they have been
very skeptical of their leadership so
far okay so thank you for trying to
clarify